un varicocele es un grupo de vasos
sanguíneos inflamados denominados venas
en el escroto del hombre
el sistema reproductor del hombre
incluye los testículos que son dos
glándulas dentro de una bolsa de piel
denominada escroto
y los testículos normalmente producen y
almacenan células reproductoras
denominadas esperma
también producen una hormona denominada
testosterona la testosterona es
importante para la producción de esperma
la fortaleza muscular y el deseo sexual
el escroto se encuentra fuera del cuerpo
para mantener los testículos lo
suficientemente fríos como para producir
esperma cada testículo está suspendido
dentro del escroto por una estructura
denominada cordón espermático dentro de
cada cordón se encuentran vasos
sanguíneos y un tubo por el que pasa el
esperma denominado conducto deferente
y la arteria testicular es el vaso
sanguíneo que lleva la mayor cantidad de
sangre al testículo la mayoría de la
sangre sale del testículo a través de un
grupo de venas denominadas plexo pampín
y forme la sangre también sale del
testículo a través de un grupo de venas
más pequeñas junto al conducto deferente
que rodean el plexo pampín y forme desde
el plexo pampín y forme la sangre fluye
a las venas testicular es
una serie de válvulas unidireccionales
dentro de las venas testiculares evitan
que la sangre regrese a los testículos
un varicocele puede comenzar a formarse
cuando las válvulas dentro de la vena
testicular están dañadas o no funcionan
correctamente
es posible que las válvulas no se
cierren completamente y permitan que la
sangre regrese dentro de la vena al
testículo
además debido a que la vena testicular
izquierda es más recta y más larga que
la vena testicular derecha hay mayor
presión descendente de sangre dentro de
la vena izquierda
es posible que se produzca otro problema
donde la vena testicular izquierda se
conecta con una vena más grande que
proviene del riñón denominada vena renal
izquierda una arteria que va a los
intestinos puede apretar la vena renal
izquierda y provocar que la sangre
regrese a la vena testicular izquierda
esto se conoce como el síndrome del
cascanueces como resultado de cualquiera
de estos problemas se puede formar un
varicocele en el plexo pampín y forme
cuando la sangre empieza a regresar a él
la acumulación de sangre en estas venas
provoca su inflamación
según la gravedad del varicocele la
sangre acumulada puede elevar la
temperatura alrededor del testículo
esta temperatura elevada puede
dificultar que el testículo produzca
esperma esta condición puede disminuir
la fertilidad que es la capacidad de
lograr el embarazo de una mujer
con el tiempo un varicocele también
puede disminuir el nivel de testosterona
que producen los testículos
y el bajo nivel de testosterona puede
producir menos energía y fortaleza
muscular así como problemas sexuales
un varicocele generalmente no causa
síntomas ni requiere tratamiento sin
embargo si un varicocele produce dolor
incomodidad o problemas con la
fertilidad el tratamiento más común es
un abanico selecto ni a micro quirúrgica
inguinal o sub inguinal
para comenzar el cirujano realizará una
pequeña incisión en la parte baja de la
ingle para una barrica o selecto ni a su
being inal o un poco más arriba para un
abanico selecto mía inguinal
luego se jala hacia afuera el cordón
espermático a través de la incisión
el cirujano abrirá el tejido exterior
del cordón espermático y separará el
varicocele del resto del tejido
colocara pequeñas pinzas metálicas en
las venas
luego cortará las venas
después de cortar las venas la sangre
aún podrá salir del testículo a través
de las venas más pequeñas en el conducto
deferente estas venas tienen menos
probabilidades de inflamarse el cirujano
finalizará el procedimiento
colocando el cordón espermático
nuevamente en su lugar a través de la
incisión en la piel y cerrará la
incisión con suturas y cinta de sutura
cutánea también se pueden realizar otros
procedimientos para reparar un
varicocele que incluyen un abanico
selecto mía laparoscópica o embolización
percutánea del varicocele